Костянтинівка в минулому була
потужним промисловим центром.
Наприклад, Краматорськ
досі працює у цьому напрямі.
У нас близько 20 років цього немає.
Коли все припинилося і зникли робочі місця,
звісно, всі були дуже засмучені.
Дуже нарікали.
Це тривало протягом поколінь
і місто стало депресивним.
Ми намагаємося залучити
якомога більшу кількість людей,
котрі хочуть щось робити.
Вільний простір «DRUZI» —
це одна з молодіжних платформ,
які діють у Луганській і Донецькій областях.
Це місце, яке ми створили
для спілкування і спільного навчання.
Інколи потусити.
Також з метою створення ідей для розвитку міста.
Щоб змінити думки людей,
які тут живуть.
У цьому куточку, як ми задумували,
коли тільки створювали простір,
повинні були сидіти люди,
які не хочуть спілкуватися ні з ким, —
це був куточок інтроверта для того,
щоб можна було почитати, повчитися.
В принципі, так воно і є.
У цьому місці ми поставили полички
для мінібібліотеки та настільних ігор.
Колись тут був китайський ресторан і коралові стіни,
які ми перефарбували.
Але вирішили не прибирати барну стійку —
це куточок для людей,
які тут працюють, тут лежать наші речі.
робимо каву і бутерброди.
У нас маленьке приміщення,
але воно безкоштовне.
Його виділила Міська Рада
для нашої громадської організації
за символічну оплату оренди — 1 гривня на рік.
Раніше, у Костянтинівці, якщо робили заходи,
то лише з ініціативи міської адміністрації.
На сьогодні мешканці Російської Федерації,
напевно, робили з'їзди мотоциклістів.
Такі масштабні заходи.
А маленькі групки,
навіть не громадські організації,
ніколи не організовували [подібні події].
Це дуже складно.
Менше з тим, ми пройшли десять кіл пекла
і вже зараз це відбувається так:
я навіть у Вайбері можу кинути заявку.
Довелося вивховувати їх два роки.
Костянтинівка — це місто, де концентруються
життєствердні ініціативи.
Попри всі негаразди, навіть
коли ми щось робимо, а нам руйнують,
ми кажемо: «Окей, значить так мало статися».
І ми прсто рухаємося далі.
Ми починаємо із того, що,
можливо, ми щось зробили не так.
І рухаємося в іншому напрямі.
І коли розповідаєш про це, завжди кажеш,
що нас, напевне, найбільше об'єднує непояснювана,
невимовна любов до Костянтинівки.
Її важко пояснити, коли відбуваються погані речі,
але ти все одно робиш далі щось хороше,
бо віриш у те, що все буде добре.
На цьому пункті ми об'єднались
і почали працювати.
У мене народився син вісім років тому.
У нього були деякі особливості...
Синдром дефіциту уваги і гіперактивності.
Невропатолог пропонував
лише якісь лікарські засоби.
Я зрозуміла, що це не допоможе моїй дитині.
Тому я почала...
самостійно знаходити способи,
щоб йому допомогти.
Навчалася на кількох семінарах.
[російською] О, полетіли авто.
[російською] Наливай воду...
[російською] Вау, так!
[російською] Ой, розлили, ну нічого, буває.
Два роки тому до мене почали звертатися люди.
Знайомі знайомих,
які знали, що я допомогла своєму сину.
Вони запитували, чи можу я допомогти їхнім дітям.
Відтоді я почала працювати з дітками.
Я працюю з дітьми з аутизмом,
із затримками мовлення.
З різноманітними особливостями у розвитку.
[російською] Показуй жестами: ку-ті...
[російською] Молодець!
[російською] Кручу, кручу кручу!
[російською] Що мені робити?
[російською] Ку-ті!
В Костянтинівці у мене близько 15 дітей.
У Краматорську люди тільки починають
приходити — там 4 дитини.
Я виграла невеличкий ґрант
і придбала меблі, інтерактивну дошку
та ще деяке обладнання.
Ма-ма.
Ма-ма!
Ма-маа...
[російською] Мама іде! Ура!
Мені дуже хотілося б зробити дитячий садочок
для дітей з особливостями розвитку.
Тому що таких діток
ніхто не хоче брати до садочків.
Якщо дитина буде перебувати
у такій розвиваючій атмосфері від ранку до вечора —
у дитини з'явиться шанс [підготуватися] до школи.
Стати досить соціалізованою дитиною
і розвинути навички, які будуть необхідні у житті.
[російською] Перед вами торговий комплекс «Україна»,
[російською] колись центральний універмаг Костянтинівки.
[російською] На сьогодні
[російською] ми його намагаємось відродити.
[російською] Так само, як і наше підприємство.
[російською] Символічно...
[російською] У Донецьку ми шили одяг для дітей.
[російською] Так вийшло, що ми переїхали
і продовжили  робити це тут.
[російською] Це моя дружина, Наталя.
[російською] Вона займається
більшою частиною справ, що тут відбуваються.
[російською] На сьогодні в Україні
великий попит на вишиванки.
[російською] Ми додали до своєї пропозиції
[російською] ось таку продукцію.
[російською] Схоже на те,
що батьки почали привчати дітей.
[російською] Хочуть ідентифікувати себе, як українці.
[російською] Звісно, це має гарний вигляд.
[російською] Нам є куди розвиватися.
[російською] Звісно...
[російською] Надіємось,
[російською] що ми не одинаки у розвитку
підприємницької діяльності Костянтинівки.
[російською] Що підприємництво буде рости.
[російською] Ми віримо в потенціал міста й України...